monde russe 15 blackies avant l'école
comment aimez-vous ce monde russe
[musique]
mariupol burlyaev sera aujourd'hui
autre récepteur d'aviation de récolte
artillerie
projet de système de volée dont il se souvient
la valeur de mariupol est devenue ce n'est pas un siècle
Je défends si les guerriers sont devenus le mari de ceux qui enlèvent
Au baron, je ferme toute l'Ukraine, essaie
pour mon expérience ils trouveront mes champs pour l'année
Ukraine
[musique]
nous avons reçu la confirmation ce matin
de la Fédération de Russie du ministère
défense de la fédération de russie qui passe
de mariupol à la ville de zaporozhye vora
le dniepr est en sécurité avec des signes comme celui-ci
avec le soutien de la Croix-Rouge, nous devons
se dirigeaient vers la ville
Zaporijia, malheureusement
le moment où nous étions déjà prêts a commencé
bombardement de l'armée régulière de la Russie
fédération le long du corridor le long duquel
nous avons dû déménager
Je peux jouer et je suis à la maison
ensuite elle est là tu perds donc pour
J'avais des barbes à 14 bras et et
épouses de sorcières tu n'es pas il ils l'ont emmené
encore plus de leurs enfants, nos rivières, nous savions
et
[musique]
voici la cour
maternité
[musique]
les enfants étaient la somme de
andra
[musique]
bombardement
nouvelle maison
[musique]